I'm Jake and this is my brother Max my
brother is autistic and my mom says he's
the form of autism called a savant
that's Jake and Max tilk as kids when
they first started using social media to
raise awareness about autism now the
brothers are all grown up and they're
still added their Tick Tock account my
brother Max has more than 880
000 followers it gives people an inside
look at life with autism take a look
Max what are you doing give me the wood
you're loading up all the trees
nice job nice job Max is a big
Lumberjack big gumbo Jack
Max and Jake tilt traveled here all the
way from Michigan to help us highlight
autism acceptance month good morning to
you tell you how you guys doing good
morning good morning good morning so so
max this Tick Tock has more than 880 000
followers how does it feel that people
are tuning in to pay attention to you
raise awareness about autism
how's it feel Maxie it feels good huh
yeah feels really good
and Jake how does it feel I'm paying
attention
um it's actually been an amazing
opportunity to really spread Autism
Awareness acceptance and show the people
with Autism aren't somebody to be afraid
of that they have a lot of value and
skills and they can learn and love just
like everybody else and they do that Max
you know they say that you have Jake
says you have a superpower what is your
superpower super powers
yeah what's your superpower though your
dates yeah yeah and your memory yeah you
have a very good memory
yeah you wanted to come to New York why
Jake
we wanted to come to New York to just
show the world that people with Autism
have value and that autism is a
superpower and to show that people like
Max aren't scary and that they can
really really change the difference and
I think in society hi hi what's up Max
I'm on Mimi's Mission yeah
I think I think in society there are so
many people that don't understand autism
that people are slightly different but
we look at it in a different light we
look at it as I've mentioned a
superpower because Max has so many
special abilities such as you know he
could tell you what day of the week any
date is if you give it to him or he can
tell you from his photographic memory
when certain things were built because
he's very interested in history and
construction and you know it's just an
amazing opportunity to show the world
that Max is an amazing dude yeah yeah
Max I like that you work at a bakery
because I like sweet things I love cake
I love cupcakes we all love cupcakes we
all love cupcakes
peanut butter peanut butter chocolate
chip oatmeal raisin chocolate chip oh
that's our favorite wine yes yes yes
what do you like about working at the
bakery Max what do you like well cookies
and bake drop cookies yeah you guys have
a lot of fun on the videos uh do you
have a favorite
um yeah my favorite video is actually
one we post a few days ago where Maxi
started his yearly Garden so max
actually loves to Garden what did you
plant in your garden
jalapenos and vegetables oh peppers in
the spring sounds
so uh you guys live in Michigan like I
said
um you guys are big Detroit Lions fans
how big huge season ticket holders over
20 years wow ever since we were little
so Maxie what year were the Detroit
Lions born
1944 1934 18 it's the fast defensive
tactical yes he is I want to hear some
more let me get a little bit more trivia
I played with Ndamukong Suh hey Max what
year did Nate Burleson start playing for
the Lions 2000
and where did he go to college at Nevada
you're right and who did he play for
after the Lions
Queen on Browns Minnesota white Kings
and Seattle Seahawks oh wow look at the
encyclopedia well I wanted to bring
something um I want to bring a little
memorabilia for you know you guys to
hold and maybe take a couple pictures
with this was a helmet that I wore while
I was playing for the Lions let's see
where it said do we have it over here oh
well and then if you can you can bring
there we go toss it to me they'll
receive so yeah I mean you can hang on
to that well actually look at that while
we're doing the rest of this interview
what do you say oh you can't you can't
necessarily you can put it on yeah it's
irresistible now you can't you can't
take that home because that's my only
helmet but you guys can take home what's
in that bag who makes you want to look
what's in this bag yeah
so that's where my secret secret stash
of lions gear that only give the family
but you guys are like family now you
signed it well thank you we feel like
family of course Maxie what do you say
thank you you're very welcome got some
short some workout gear now you're a
Lions player Jake you say Max has made
you a better person how
um so growing up with Max things were
really different so it basically growing
up it was just us two in a lot of ways
it was really hard for me to get out and
make peop make friends with people who
are I guess neurotypical so I grew up
with Max and I grew up with a deeper
understanding and compassion for people
who have special needs and um it's it's
just a beautiful way to view the world
you view the world with so much love
just like Maxi doesn't have a mean bone
in his body nice shirt
I'm glad you like your best
looks good on you nice shirt thank you
thank you Max for coming today yeah
thank you for hanging out with us thank
you thank you thank you
Jack ahead in our talk of the table a
long time dog trainer tells us who is
man's worst friend another perfect shirt
that's another perfect shirt that's what
I was saying it would be perfect on you
[Music]